comics logic is where you go to learn by
informatics including statistical
analysis
experimental design data mining and
systems biology
the portal is technology agnostic
providing browser-based big data
analysis tools coding exercises and
project examples
it is a complete road map for
bioinformatics that will guide you to
find data sets explore and visualize
them
learn about research methodology and
provide a clear understanding about
analysis techniques
that help gain insight into biological
problems by signing up you will gain
experience with methods for analysis
of big data and data wrangling following
examples of data science and application
to biomedical research
from data collection to biological
interpretation by getting started with
the logic of coding skills that you need
tutorials cover topics like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics
helping simplify these complex datasets
for visualization and biological
insights by going behind the visuals to
explain the code and help you learn
how to adapt it to your own project
providing a comprehensive
data science experience in r and python
to see how data mining and machine
learning methods are used to analyze
patterns
group data objects by feature similarity
and train machine learning models
for predictive analysis you will also
find a variety of curated research
examples and learn about the logic
behind each typogramics data
used to study cancer tissue biology and
the microbiome
using peer-reviewed publications in
precision medicine
biotechnology neuroscience and
infectious diseases